Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Are you awake?
You awake?
Are you ready for a new week?
Yeah!
Because this week's extra special!
Important, important!
It's our 3D week!
BAU BAU!
But that aside... Thank you so much for waking up and joining us today for our 114th episode!
Mama!
Yo!
CD!
Yeah!
3D!
So excited!
Don't forget Pero's birthday.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Maybe you're joining us for the first time and you don't know.
That's okay.
What's a 3D, huh?
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
Today is not FUWAMOCO.
No.
Friday, Wednesday, Monday, FUWAMOCO.
But it's hosted by FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's gonna be a good week, Ruffians.
It's gonna be a good week.
BAU BAU!
And we're stating it on the right paw because we're together.
And it's FUWAMOCO Morning for Moco-chan!
What do we have to make the day even better, huh?
Well!
De-den!
I don't see anything there but it says Pero Sighting, Moco-chan.
Well, there's been no Pero Sighting again!
Good, good start.
Ruffian.
I've really not been seeing Pero around.
I'm seeing some rumors.
Very silly rumors.
That's not factual though.
Baseless.
Baseless rumors.
He's the Great Perroccino!
His words, not mine.
Yeah.
Okay.
But I think they're strange Ruffians.
Please let us know if you see them, okay?
Okay!
Especially now it's a 3D week.
Oh yeah.
Who knows?
BAU BAU!
Organize a search!
A search?
Why would we go to that length?
I mean, you know if you're going about your day, like, what's that at all?
Let us know.
Not go like, okay, forget my day plan!
No search parties!
It's not that kind of... No search parties, a birthday party later, I guess.
FUWAMOCO, just a few days ago we released our first original song, Boy To Be Balladon!
Thank you, Ruffians!
We've already hit a huge milestone!
We hit 250,000 views on YouTube!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
We're so happy that you love it so much!
We are so excited!
Have you finally been able to listen to it too?
In case you know, we've been a little bit busy last week.
Well, it was our first year anniversary!
And we celebrate it by releasing our first original song, Born to be "BAU"DOL☆★!
It's a song written by...
PandaBoY-san.
PandaBoY-san has written a bunch of our favorite idol songs as well as hololive songs too, like Blue Clapper.
So please have a listen at here!
Yattaiga!
But here we also have a very cute little pony FUWAMOCO.
The MV was made by Sato.
Yeah, please check it out, okay?
But it means a lot because you know,
It's our first original song, and you know, it's very FUWAMOCO!
We BAU BAU.
We really like to play to one day.
1 million views one day.
Running.
Workout.
Work.
Also, we had an afterparty where we kind of shared the best way to be able to cheer for us and we performed it live and enjoyed lots and lots of all the Ruffians everywhere.
So you can check that out and let you know maybe while you're working out you can be like FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
You saved it in your holo earphones!
BAU BAU!
We're so happy to be included!
And we hope that we can release more Rachel music soon to Ruffians!
Please keep listening to it lots and lots again!
BAU BAU!
It's not easy, okay, Ruffians?
Thank you, Ruffians!
Speaking of low-poly 3D, I think I can take a little high-poly one.
Because Biboo and Shiori, they just had their 3D debut!
And first up, it was Shiori!
That was amazing, Ruffians!
You saw it, right?
It was intense!
That was so Shiori!
I was dying!
She's so cute!
It was so Shiori!
Shiori!
You know, she's so silly, just...
Shiori being Shiori, but then... Really?
You get to see her?
We were so happy to be able to be a part of it.
Yeah.
But, you know, the first song she had was Gawaii.
Yeah!
And it was so intense!
Yeah, and all of Shiori's singing practice and lessons really paid off too.
Right.
I caught goosebumps.
And then, Rainy Boots!
She danced around in the rain!
Yeah!
With her spiky boots and the umbrella.
Yeah, all the music suited her right!
I didn't know any of the songs, but now they're all hers to me.
They're all her songs now.
Yeah.
But she really did improve so much too!
I think definitely, I mean it's most of her songs, but we like got Rainy Boots and Hoshi o Watari Tori the best.
Yeah, so much.
I saw a comment that they're waiting for us to watch Shiori's.
What?
But you can get so excited and hype now and see Shiori's!
Watch them in order, okay?
Shiori, then Biboo, then Nerissa, then... What?
Shiori, then Biboo, then Shiori... That's not right!
Shiori, then Biboo, then Nerissa, then FUWAMOCO, then Advent.
Yeah!
Okay.
You had a full advent experience, right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, there was Kabedon, right?
That was... I was like, oh my goodness.
Shiori!
Yeah.
So proud of her, right?
Yeah, it's a good thing, you know, that you just cut the feed, right?
See, look how cute she is!
Yeah!
I was screaming!
Ruffians!
We were like, what?!
That's illegal!
She's illegal.
Too cute.
Yeah, it was so good, right?
How do you not just run right through the screen into her arms?
They're open!
She needs the hug!
Yeah, right.
Amazing shot.
Right at Fuwawa Cameraman.
I caught the screenshot, so thank you for the compliment.
So cute!
It was so good!
But then after that!
Look, look, look!
I just want to play that, you know?
Advent for being my supportive friends and family.
But then after that... Look, look, look!
I just wanna play that, you know?
...for being my supportive friends and family.
They're family!
Family!
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
People...
I'm so glad you went on!
You heard her original song, right, Ruffians?
Right!
Right from the very beginning!
Did you notice?
Prism no Mahou!
Yeah!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
No one's ever had the Pebblemont Party.
Right.
I feel like there was so much jam packed into it.
But we got so emotional doing Orange.
You know, Orange Heart, Oradora.
Together with Kaela-senpai!
It was so cute!
It was so cute.
Yeah.
Oh, and then there's also Gio!
Gio!
Did you notice?
We finally got to see Gio.
Gio!
He returned.
Yeah, Biboo's body.
Very cute.
Not as fluffy as me, though.
No, no.
His ears, though.
Gio's not nasty.
Do you think Gio has to take a lot of baths with ears that long?
Instead of dragging everywhere, I want them to get muddy.
Gio.
But, you know, Biboo and Shiori, they're both so good at singing!
So good!
And their dancing was so cute, too!
It's just wonderful seeing them before I was.
And look at the cute Biboo!
Yeah!
Again!
Biboo's like, I wanna hug!
Why is she always screaming so loud?
She's like, I wanna hug!
But why?
Yeah, her expressions are so cute!
Oh, now you wanna see Pero and Gio battle it out?
That would be scary.
They're both great, huh?
I wonder why what happened, huh?
Yeah.
And we both got the same screenshot!
We can't help it when Biboo is that cute, right?
So cute!
But Ruffians, you're not forgetting, right?
It's gonna be Nerissa and our CD this upcoming weekend!
Nerissa hers is on the 9th at 8pm PT.
And FUWAMOCO on the 10th at 8pm PT as well.
Please put it in your calendars!
It's not too far off!
It really isn't!
I'm really worried!
Yeah.
Yeah, so we're practicing as much as we can.
You'll be there to support us, right, Ruffians?
You'll watch with kind eyes, right?
We practiced so much, Ruffians!
We put every little bit of love and fun as we could.
So, yeah.
We're gonna do our best, okay?
Be there with headpats, okay?
Yeah.
Don't be late.
I'm so nervous.
BAU BAU!
I hope we can sleep.
It'll be there.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, BAU BAU!
And then after us, of course, there's the Advent Club the next week.
So don't forget about that, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, also, something exciting going on next weekend is the big Summer Comiket 2024!
I hear you talk about it almost every time there's Comiket, but if you're not too sure what Comiket is, it stands for Comic Market.
It's one of the biggest anime comic events in all of Japan, and it happens twice a year.
Once in summer and once in winter.
You know Comiket already, right?
Yeah, it's like the battle of the elements.
And there's cosplayers there.
Of course they have their own cosplayer area.
But mainly it's for fan-made comics, fan-made works.
There's also music, also merchandise, fan-made merchandise.
There's also an industry area as well.
So there's a bunch of different things to check out.
We are the most excited about the fan comments!
So it's the same date as our debut.
It is!
The same date as FUWAMOCO's 3D debut!
At the same time too!
Comiket starts early, only for a couple hours from the morning until the afternoon.
Well, FUWAMOCO's debut at noon JST is.
So you know, Icomochi-mama.
Icomochi-mama's gonna be a comiket.
A bit busy, huh?
Bit of a busy day, you know?
But maybe Icomochi-mama can watch at the Ruffians.
Maybe.
Watch Party.
Of course, FUWAMOCO, we'd love to go on a cool weekend, but it's a bit of a busy day for us.
Just a little bit.
I don't think we can just kind of skip out on the things we have planned that day.
I think you will be a bit sad if suddenly, where's FUWAMOCO for their 50th debut and why is it just empty?
FUWAMOCO decided to go to Big Sight!
But you know FUWAMOCO, one of my big dreams for my debut is to get our paws on FUWAMOCO family.
And Comiket is the number one place for that.
You know, for Winter Comiket, Mari-chan was able to go and get us some stuff.
We're hoping that Mori-chan can go again and get us with the... Ruffians!
Please let us know what kind of circles are selling for.
FUWAMOCO books.
Advent books.
We really want to get our paws on them.
We need to make a list so we need it a bit earlier than that.
Yeah.
A little bit earlier than that, please.
Yeah, a little bit earlier than last time, too.
Good luck, Moni-chan!
It's a battlefield!
But you know, Ruffians, you know, last time there was Winter Comiket, right?
But we had just sort of debuted.
But everyone needed to apply.
So, there wasn't... There was still lots of Advent and FUWAMOCO stuff, but it wasn't that much.
Right?
You know, we still got our hands on a lot of stuff.
And I think on some stuff that the Ruffians don't even know about.
Some very rare!
Yeah.
A bit rare, huh?
Eye treasures!
So let us know what other kind of rare treasures might be waiting that we don't know about yet.
Yeah.
Oh, the mochi!
Yeah!
Breaking it.
BAU BAU!
Wow.
I noticed, Ruffians, that there's been some silly things going on on Twitter.
When are there not silly things going on on Twitter?
Yeah.
Let's take a look at this first one here.
It seems like Moco-chan, you've been replaced.
Wow.
There's been some shady business going on, and there have been some people reselling merch from the big hololive City event going on.
But this time, with a new angle.
Look at this FUWAMOCO badge set!
Huh?
Ruffians!
Does something look a little bit off?
Huh?
You see, Fuwawa, I'm there!
I'm fluffy!
I'm there, you know!
Oh, somebody there next to me, they have dog ears.
Up there, I'm blue.
Moco-chan's pink.
Yeah.
I'm not Koyori!
I'm Mococo!
BAU BAU!
It's Fuwa... Fuwakoyo!
Fuwakoyo!
Or you could be Mocoyo!
Moco-chan, I'm Mocoyo!
But that would just be me and Koyori-senpai.
That's true.
Fuwakoyo!
BAU BAU!
Goodbye, Moco-chan.
Koyori-senpai is here!
She's all ready!
Bye, Moco-chan!
Are you just gonna do FUWAMOCO Morning without me, with Koyori-senpai instead?
Oh, it's possible.
But good luck doing, uh... Asa... Asa Coco.
What?
No way!
No.
We're not switching.
No switching, Moco-chan!
You're forever going to FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO is FUWAMOCO because FUWA plus MOCO.
FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Right.
No more silly business, okay?
No more silly business!
Moco-chan is Moco-chan.
Yeah.
She's the fuzzy one.
Got it, Ruffian?
Yeah.
Silly Risa was hot!
But I'm happy though because I love Koyari-senpai too!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians!
The Twitter silly business continues here!
Does it?
It does!
Let me take a look, Moco-chan.
Huh?
Well, it seems like Ruffians
MisDo!
They have a new pon-de-ring coming up!
What?
And it looks super duper delicious!
Of course, naturally, FUWAMOCO, we have our eyes on it.
But... What?
There's also been a bunch of Ruffians who've been letting us know about the joyous news, too!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
There's been a number of you, too!
Right!
Yeah, it looks super delicious, but...
I've also been thinking of FUWAMOCO and you see pon-de-rings!
It makes me so happy!
But, you know, on Twitter, when you search up FUWAMOCO, for some reason, Twitter now pushes all the tweets from the official MisDo Twitter account about pon-de-rings to you.
So you search up FUWAMOCO,
That tweet come up too.
It's not promoted or anything.
It's not promoted.
It's just Twitter's algorithm.
Yeah.
Twitter knows.
Twitter knows how much FUWAMOCO loves porn right now.
And at first, like, I noticed it and I was like, oh, that's silly.
That's silly, but then- Thank you.
There's been other Ruffians noticing this too.
I don't know.
But... It makes me happy to think that Twitter recognizes our love for pon-de-ring too!
Yeah, we've been recognized!
Yeah!
Maybe one day, you know?
That would be nice.
But for now, we'll continue to love pon-de-ring!
We're excited to go try the new pon-de-ring once it's released!
Oh my gosh, I wonder how juicy and tender it'll be.
Delicious it's gonna be.
Soft, very soft.
Very soft.
BAU BAU!
I wonder if they'll ever make a more delicious pon-de-ring than the pon-de-ring's already existing.
It's not possible.
I don't know.
BAU BAU!
Live up for you!
Let's take a look at the Doggie of the Day today!
The Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
GARY!
GARY IS THE Doggie of the Day!
That's a very delicious tail you have up there.
It's just a normal doggy tail, that's all, you know.
Normal brown colored doggy.
Floppy ears.
Right, right.
Somehow the ties look really enticing, huh?
Every doggy ties look enticing, right Moco-chan?
Something about these ones look more enticing.
I don't know, maybe, maybe, you know, maybe it's just a funny morning. Maybe we're feeling a little funnier than usual, Moco-chan. I wanna hear you!
How did she BAU BAU?
I wanna hear it
That was scary, BAU BAU.
I have a feeling it's a very unique BAU BAU.
Oh?
Kinda like... Like that!
Like that!
Kinda sounds like a BAU BAU.
It's a very unique BAU BAU.
Very unique, right?
Game, why are you making that face?! !
You look sort of uncomfortable.
And I like it.
I like it!
Very cute.
BAU BAU, Kirari.
BAU BAU!
I wanna see more pictures of the doggy.
Very interesting doggy.
BAU BAU!
The stripes are enticing too there.
The chin there enticing too.
The little pink on those there.
BAU BAU!
Very tasty dog.
Let's see Ruffians, have you been going on any nice summertime walks?
Yeah!
We have de-den!
Oh my gosh!
A full walk!
You got the whole gang with you!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Us!
Super cute!
They just look like doggies in a can.
BAU BAU!
They're so so happy!
And the scenery looks so nice and green.
Very luscious.
Very nice summertime look.
Thank you for taking us all together with you!
BAU BAU!
Next, we have our Question of the Day.
Our Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hi, FUWAMOCO!
When you receive doujinshi or other pieces of family... Receive.
Receive?
That's what I said.
BAU BAU!
How fluffy and fuzzy are we to you, you know?
But, you know, of course we're also really interested in everyone's thoughts and interpretation, but we're also really happy when we're portrayed really close to how we are here!
Yeah, that means you're watching closely, too.
You know, I feel like sometimes it's a little bit like, when things are kind of changed, you know?
Especially, you know, in the case of Moco-chan from L.A.
You know, I'm fuzzy, not fluffy, okay?
I'm Mococo!
What is?
If it looks too different from how we are regularly, you know, it kind of starts to feel like a cosplay instead of us, so we kind of feel like, aww, okay.
Yeah, and you know, if Fuwawa says stuff like Mococo instead of Moco-chan, you know, it sort of takes us off from the world building too high.
Mococo!
Don't go that way!
It's not right.
It should be Moco-chan.
Yeah.
If we don't BAU BAU, then something's really wrong!
But we really like serious moments!
Please tell us how you like this year's Ruffians, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
We're always looking for more questions!
Doggy of the days!
Your walks, Pero Sightings, all of it!
So please let us know with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
As for our next stream, we have De-den!
We'll be meeting Super Chats and chatting with a bunch of Ruffians!
It's gonna be
Probably a good time chatting all together.
There's been a bunch of exciting things so we want to be able to talk but I still feel like we haven't been able to reminisce enough.
Last time was pretty silly, I think this time's gonna be even more silly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, please join us, Ruffians!
And let's take a look at our schedule this week.
Our schedule!
3D week schedule!
Yeah!
And on Tuesday, we're also gonna be playing Sakura Wars 5!
It's been a little while!
But we need to get ready for New York City.
We do!
We have breaking dimensions in New York City, so we'll have to see if they have birds.
Yep.
So we're gonna go back to Summer Voice 5 and get all adjusted to New York.
Yes!
Then we'll be all ready at the end of this month.
And then on Wednesday we have FUWAMOCO Morning and Portal 2!
We're finally playing Portal 2 for the first time on Thursday.
I don't know why this is here.
It's Pero's birthday.
I guess it's gonna be a party.
Friday we have Nerissa's 3D debut at 8pm PT.
And then on Saturday, it's our 3D debut!
Please be there, Ruffians!
And on Sunday, we have a lot to do.
Let's talk about because it's going to be our 3D debut after party!
Please be there.
There's so much we're going to want to talk about.
You want to be there for our 3D debut, of course, but also our after party.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Ruffians who are joining us through the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO with... It's BAU BAU 3D!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so so much, Ruffians, for joining us today, the very beginning of our 3D week, and for joining us for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
Toshiro Iwai!
BAU BAU!
Nekiso Jedon!
Heart Crayon!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!